hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2019 3d World Team
Championship it's India versus Russia we
already said that this will be quite a
matchup now for Russia this match
doesn't really hold any significance
ranking wise Russia already won first
place basically in the penultimate round
having having three points advantage
ahead of everyone else but for India
it's a different case since India really
started China really started doing well
and well India would really like to win
this match
you know when at least at least the
third or second place in the in the
championship but for Russia you know
anything can happen they are just here
to enjoy chess and I think that's the
the the best game that you can play when
you're playing in a championship so we
do have a couple of photos although it's
the same one from the previous video so
I'm not gonna show now I'm gonna show
later I know it's it's weird we always
have a nice oblique photo when he's not
playing the game when but when he is
playing the game then we don't have any
you know yeah what are you gonna do but
okay
Greece Chuck has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 let me just fix that we
have nice to have six c4 with East six
nine to f3 and now d5 we transpose into
the Queen's Gambit the client Knights
the c3 and Bishop to b4 Dora goes in
defense
we have seek after spawn captures and
Bishop to g5 pinning the night here and
now the immediate h6 asking do you want
a trade or do you want to go back with
Bishop to h4 castles by c2 Ramon and now
comes a e3 sort of III with Bishop to a5
Queen to b3 now attacking the bishop now
either the bishop will go back but then
you lose the b7 pawn so you do have to
capture here with Bishop captures Queen
captures and this position has been
reached plenty of times there's a very
very famous game Madera versus cousin
where Carson went night be d7 that game
ended in a draw
I was play the last year in 2018 in the
European Club Cup championship but here
we have g5 and it's also a known move
Bishop to g3 and not Knights to e4
attacking the queen but also pressuring
the bishop here on g3 and here we have
Queen captures on c7 black sacrifices
upon for some activity and there's also
a unknown game ding leerin versus Oregon
that ended in a draw in 2017 played in
palma de mallorca Dengler and continued
with nice to see six but here we have
the immediate Queen captures on c7 and
okay Bishop captures and only now Knight
to c6 and Bishop to b5 white now once
the capture here and well there's not
all that much black I can do we have
look F to c8 and going after the bishop
and here Bishop captures and c6 now
which Bishop do you capture well of
course you do want to capture the light
square bishop as your d5 pawn is hanging
so pawn captures and Bishop to a5 we
have looked look a to b8 pressuring the
b2 pawn and now b4 and if you look at
this position white now has a well
somewhat weird the bishop on a5 but on
the other hand with the b4 point and the
d4 point you have an excellent c5
outpost for well maybe your knight in
the future but also you are preventing
black from pushing c5 himself so if
you're taking that into consideration
black now has a backwards c6 pawn which
is a weak bond and the white will well
try to try to do something about it
sorry about that
we have Knight to d6 black now wants to
attack the bishop and well make make
some activity for his rooks nice to d2
grease Chuck is just in time to prevent
this we have nice to b7 and not nice to
be 3 and here while you can capture
after pawn captures you're still not too
gaining any activity you can you cannot
use the B file due to the night and the
night and pawn still control the c5
square so c5 will never be an option so
first we have Bishop the c2 by storm on
attacking the defender of the bishop
here but now just bush and Knights the
c5 here agree ship is asking do you want
to capture the bishop or the night you
could capture the bishop and after
Bishop the pawn captures the rook to be
2 you gain a lot of activity and it
doesn't seem to be playable but Citarum
on the side
for a different option he goes Knight
captures on c5 with D captures now the B
file is still closed and now rook to e8
hoping for a rookie for to c4 with a
four by Grichuk now comes Bishop to F
Bishop back to a5 queenside castle and
now rook to e4 and now Grisha blocks the
rock rook to d4
we have rook captures pawn captures and
now better the back to thee seven
helping out with the the defense of b5
might be an option in some situations if
the rook ever leaves the B file so kink
the d2 we have rook to e8 now taking
control of the only open file on the
board and now Bishop to c7
we have f6 by black and now comes f3
Grisha key is reluctant to go rook to e1
black would happily trade rooks black is
down upon but it's a it's an opposite
called Bishop endgame and the wild those
can be won this one would most likely be
a draw so here we have a six by black
that with further control against the d5
square B five square G 4 I meant g4 King
to g7 black just improves and looked the
c1 like can't really look it doesn't
have an active plan here black can just
wait he's down upon if you know if
Greece Chuck doesn't pull anything off
it will most likely be a draw so it's
basically up to white if he will attempt
something and here look to see one
already it's a very threatening move for
example if you play a waiting move it's
a king's usage then b5 is a threat
because now after captures captures and
captures you get c6 now the bishop has
to move you go Bishop d6 now you prepare
to push your pawn and after rook here
but upon here you your Bishop and rook
will be stuck for the rest of the game
keeping an eye on the c8 square and it
will be just a terrible position for for
black to be and your you can just bring
the King the deeper into the position
move let's say move the bishop then
bring the King all the way in white will
just be much better or most likely even
winning so after Luke 2 c1 as the
tournament of course does not allow this
we have looked at a six reinforcing the
c6 square and now just h3 and now we'll
have a couple of you know
testing moves kingís 7 Russia back to g3
with Russian 3e8
Bishop to f2 Bishop to d7 Bishop to e3
King g7 and now F for Greece Chuck now
wants to trade down all of the points
and the King said and focus on the game
on the Queen side and somehow somehow
try to get some activity for his rook G
captures an F for we have Bishop
captures an F for King to g6 and now
Russia back to III King back to g7 kingi
to kink the g6 came to F to Bishop to e8
and now King back to e2 we have Bishop
back to D seven again black is waiting
to see if white is interested in taking
the draw and I do have to mention that
while they are playing this game the
other games between well Russian and
Indian players are really crazy ok
kurakin and Adi bun on board one it was
pretty much pretty much a solid to draw
but all the other games were really
crazy we're gonna mention that a bit
after after this game King to have three
Russia back to e8 King F to the move 40
has been reached so time control has
been reached and players have been
granted additional time Bishop d7 kink
kinky - Bishop e8 King d3 Russia back to
d7 Bishop d2 King g7 just Bishop to f4
King g6 and now Bishop to g3 ping g5
Bishop the e1 Bishop - eh and now Bishop
the d2 check here something finally
happens agree shook is x asking I do
want to go here and make this pawn trade
where I can go g5 and try and trade
everything off like taking g4 captures
captures and then I will transfer the
game over to the Queen side maybe try
and activate my rook set Roman is a not
interested he wasn't King back to g6 and
now we have rook to f1 and okay King
back to g7 now comes H for Bishop to d7
and here finally g5 agora ship is now
successful in his attempt to trade off
everything on the kingside
f captures we have pawn captures and now
not captures but rather h5 black still
wants to keep the Kings eyes closed with
Bishop to f4 now comes King to g6 and
now a very nice move Bishop to e5 where
if you capture the pawn now
route 7 and well you have to move the
bishop and then Luke a7 picks up this
pawn black of course does not want to
allow this so we have Bishop back to be
8 now comes King III King capture son g5
and now rook to g1 check we have King to
h6 now comes rook to g8 finally Greece
ship temporarily gives back the pawn
although it will be very hard to hold on
to it but he manages to activate his
rook rook to e7 we have King King back
King to f4 Luke - Luke to f7 check King
back to g3 rook to e7 back just came to
h4 now preparing this check to pick up
the pawn and only then will Greece Chuck
try and figure out how to switch his
pieces over to the Queen side we have
rook to e6 we have group to H a check as
planned King to g6 and now rook captures
on h5 so as we mentioned that the pawn
sacrifice was only temporary
the ponies picked up and now well you
have to try again and get to this rook
somehow over to the Queen side route
back to e7 we have worked the g5 check
King f7 and now King to g4 King to e6
with rook to g8 now comes King to f7 and
now rope to h8 King to g6 we have looked
to f8 now cutting the King off from from
bf file Bishop d7 check King to g3 and
here well you don't want to allow rook
to to go over there and if you try
something like rook to e8 its I mean
it's possible but not really
mmm something of course white will not
trade that you will first give a check
after the King moves now you will force
the bishop to move and after the bishop
moves you will go to a7 and start you
know gobbling up the pawns from from the
Queen side and if black will try real
hard to defend it you can even just
bring your King into the game so here we
have a different idea here bishop
displayed the tournament just closes the
the eighth-ranked from greece rook but
it doesn't work here Grisha perfectly
set up the position everything is you
know where it's supposed to be see
pause the video here and try to find the
winning move for white I'll give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
winner of Vita World Team Championships
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show the move you have to play now is b5
it was a threat somewhere some 50 moves
ago but now it also becomes a threat
because the rook now occupies the final
rank or the eighth rank and it well the
idea becomes again possible it captures
a capture so this was played you don't
want to allow b6 so C captures and now
comes c6 and this is the problem the
king is in g6 and if you capture you get
root of 6 check the bishop gets picked
up and what white will just have a
winning endgame black will be able to
harass quite a bit but sooner or later
both of these points will be lost and
the game is not one
so after c6 settlement tried before but
not just c7 with Bishop to d7 and here a
Grisha played c8 he brought the Queen
immediately into the game but there were
also some possibilities of ideas like
group to f6 check and then if let's say
King g5 rook d6 threatening captures and
then if rook recapture student bring the
Queen into the game or if you block then
just Bishop f6 check picks up the rook
which was one way to go AG research
shows a different line he chose upon to
see it and he brought the Queen into the
game Bishop captures we have rook
captures now white is up upper piece
rook to b7 and now comes
well it's interesting what comes now I
can't feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the easiest way to you
know convert your advantage into a full
point I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who found the rook to
b8 that's a terrible move if you found
work to be 8 then black could just
capture it and after b3 you have no ways
of stopping the pawn as your own d4 pawn
is preventing you from controlling the
b2 squared so hopefully none of you
found did that move but if you found
something like King to before the only
move that wins then congratulations you
are yet again NX
Claire you just made the room for your
rook you're threatening this check rook
is coming over to g1 and then to be won
and then the pawn is stopped
so here b3 was played we have checked
King has to move rook to G 1 B 2 and now
rook to be won
the point is not stopped and as the
bishop is nicely controlling the pawn on
d4 the pawn is controlling the bishop on
e5 this is you know rock-solid
the King now just has to come here pick
up the pawn and continue playing the
game the game continued in g6 we have
King III King at 5 King to b3 looked to
b5 now just the King to c3 rugby 7 and
now finally rook captures on b2 black of
course cannot trade if you trade you
lose the game
so black tried rook to h7 but now just a
rookie to rope to East 7 was played and
King to before and well it was in this
position on the move 85 that the
tournament resigned the game and this
victory by Alexander II shook did not
bring Russia first the first place here
but it did bring them out a victory over
India in this in this very intense match
here we can show one line that wins
let's say you have to make a move King G
for now just king c5 you bring your King
into the position and if black will try
to defend the pawn you just attack it
and now just look after whatever black
plays you can't attack the root because
you no longer have pressure against the
pawn but here after any move black makes
you just go let's say rook f6 or even
better you can go rook rook f7 to go
here King to g4 now you can just block
and after the rook moves wherever the
rule goes you can just capture the pawn
now I just move the king and the pawn
Queens there's not much blood can do
here not nothing at all sure after
Kingdom before a storm on I resigned the
game and let's just check this out these
are the results from all the boards
Russia vs. India like we said
mentioned Kerrigan versus the audubon it
was a pretty pretty solid draw then the
opponent issue versus Ganguly it was
really a crazy game an information she
was down down a piece and he was
supposed to lose Ganguly had a winning
position but India and somehow you know
and never worked his magic and ended up
getting a draw on Dracon versus our I
mean and Reagan was also winning in at
one moment but he didn't find the
correct continuation the game ended in a
draw
and then you have this game Chris
Chuck's a tournament which was most like
the most draws game of them all and the
only game that ended in a win so once
again you know chess is funny like that
that will happen you know it was the
game that was least likely to not end up
in a draw and ended up in a win yeah
something like that so yeah and here we
have the standings after you know the
final round Russia in the first place
with 16 match points again three points
ahead of everyone else England in second
place with 13 and you have China who has
overtaken India with third place was
China wins the the bronze trophy India
unfortunately no trophies for them even
though they played an excellent
tournament and only only succumbed to
Russia in the final round and it was
amazing no one thought that China even
had a chance of winning winning any
prizes because they had a terrible start
but then you know everything just
started going in their favor then okay
if it plays USA six place Iran seven
place Azerbaijan eighth place Kazakhstan
ninth place Sweden and in last place we
have Egypt so there we have it the final
standings of the 2019 were a feeder
world Team Championship from the open
section we will we are gonna check up on
some of the games from the women's
section as well and if I managed to find
any any nicer ones I will show them if
you have any suggestions from the
women's section feel free also to use
hashtag suggestion to help me you know
locate some some nicer games oh yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
for the end I promise you a nice Greek
photo maybe if you haven't seen my
previous video there you have it let's
just enjoy it for a second
and yeah like I said tomorrow
feel free to tune in at 6 p.m. Central
European Time and we're gonna have a
nicely chess tournament I will be
streaming it I will not be having a lot
of time tomorrow
so I will probably scream for like an
hour and a half but we are gonna repeat
that tournament every Friday and then I
will be trying to get back into
streaming where you know we're gonna
have a tournament and then I'm gonna
access accepts on challenges we're gonna
have some fun it's gonna be it's gonna
be pretty awesome hopefully but yeah and
also the second video today came a bit
earlier because I will be uploading the
third video today it will be the
subscribers video 2019 you've been
waiting for it for such a long time
so just to you know mention that as well
and of course I would like to thank
Benito Camila Roy Branford halyard a
Maryland's Neto hunter icon and Steven
Steve Rockies for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content we are now continuing the
capablanca saga very soon and of course
I'm checking up on your suggestions as
usual thank you all and have an
excellent rest of your day and I will
see you soon